that was there was an ad Association
survey about six months ago straight
after breakfast where you know seventy
percent of people were very nervous
about the future and as I suppose the
whole country was in all of business has
been but advertising a bit like other
sectors has sort of defied what a lot of
the doom mongers thought so we saw last
quarters figures showed a four point two
percent rise in an ad spend now what
happens in the future i think is still
very much up for grabs but you know as
we go into this summit tomorrow the lead
summit you know the big issues for the
advertising industry i think are making
sure that the position that we've got
sort of post brexit and even pre brexit
has maintained as an industry knows you
know we're exporting over four billion
of advertising services into europe my
own and partnership you know one of our
biggest contracts in the history of our
company was awarded to us last autumn
post brexit out of a french based
network into a london-based network and
it's very important for us and for our
industry that government makes sure that
as we go into brexit they're very
cognizant of the things that we need to
protect in order for us to continue to
be the strong sector that we are how
dependent is the industry on migrant
labor and how much of a hit would it be
if there were curbs on immigration so
that would be I think a big issue for
our industry you know I think one of the
I think there are a number of strengths
that our industry has historically
London has had grew some of the best
advertising agency brands in the world
starting with the saatchi brothers and
CDP and we've managed to maintain that I
think partly because we've attracted one
in five people in the advertising
business have come from Europe brother
countries as well as Brazil the US etc
fury young Brazilian creative there's no
better place than two were then at a top
London agency same thing if you're a
young German creative
I think our cell to global brands
European brands is if you hub your
creativity for Europe out of London one
of the reasons that's a good thing to do
is not just a sort of historical levels
of excellence really if you look at
creative awards but also our ability to
attract the best European talent in here
so it's very important to us as an
industry that as we go into those brexit
negotiations our ability to hire and
bring in those one in five foreign
talents from Europe and elsewhere is
it's completely maintained and as you
look ahead towards the rest of 2017
what's the mood among clients in terms
of ad spending are they looking to
commit the budgets that they have done
over the last 18 months or so again I
think I think the thing that the ad
spenders are looking for is like
everybody a degrees of certainty you
know if you're going to invest in a
brand often it doesn't pay back that
investment till year two three four and
five so I think they want to know that
there's going to be a stable regulatory
environment so that's quite important
for sectors like food gambling you know
etc where there's been some
controversies in the past around that we
wanted we want a stable environment for
those for those advertisers by your
position personally I keep reading that
you're the heir apparent to Sir Martin
Sorrell if he ever finally hangs up his
boots at wpp this is a story I know
Martin loves me discussing and now i
think as as as you probably know because
you see quite a lot of him you know
Martin looks about 32 years old he's
just had a kid he's probably the most
active energetic businessman in the
world so when they say are you likely to
take over for him if if I ever was I
don't think it'll be for 15 or 20 years
time I think Martin's got you know a
long long run and you know as you've
seen continues to post fantastic results
somebody once actually said that the
person that you know succeeds Martin's
are all probably like you know David
Moyes succeeding Alex Ferguson it might
not be a job that you'd want to take on
after the long run of success he's head